hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
played in 1883 in London between
Johannes Zucker tor and Joseph Henry
Blackburn this game is now known today
as sucker tortes immortal so let's see
exactly what went on that made this game
so special
sucker tor on the white end opening with
c4 English opening and a six is
signaling the agging court defense
something that I'm not too too familiar
with and something that's not so common
today but it can certainly transpose
into let's say a Queen's Gambit in just
a couple moves but we don't have that
after this east six move we have III so
these two particular pawn moves to a III
and E six are pretty much saying that
the Queen bishops are going to be fee in
Quetta because going along that main
diagonal not really gonna be a very
likely thing to occur for either of
those bishops so you can already
anticipate that and sure enough in this
game we see it but more development in
the meantime Knight f6 Knight f3 b6
Bishop e2 a tame deployment of this
Bishop you could also see let's say d4
first and the bishop being deployed to
that d3 square we actually see that on
the black end but first Bishop b7 white
castles and now d5 black is intending on
posting that Bishop to d6 where it will
eventually support upon to e5 advance
okay and so at this point white
establishes this pawn in the center and
black goes with Bishop to d6 looking to
eventually place their queen on e7 and
maybe get this efj I've advanced in but
in this game it does not occur instead
Knight c3
black castles b3 so be encountering the
Queen Bishop here for White Knight B to
d7 more development keeping a watchful
eye in fact on both of these squares you
may very well see c5 or 'if I've in such
a pawn structure striking at White's
lead pawn in the center that d4 square
so Bishop b2 and now this right here
this last move by black Queen d7 is a
serious commitment at this point because
there really isn't any significant
imbalance in the position
with regard to the pawn structure really
not too much of a difference regarding
the pawn structure in fact everything is
pretty much identical except the C pawns
White has advanced their C pun and black
is still on its home square everything
else is pretty much identical and so
with Queen d7 White replies 92 b5 and
what's going to happen now is one of
those main imbalances in a chess game a
knife for Bishop exchange that that in
fact cannot be avoided the bishop plays
here you can always put a question to it
so this exchange is going to happen and
black must have seen that and thought
that they were going to be able to make
better use of that imbalance they were
going to be able to make use of their
night and try and shut down this dark
square bishop so we have 94 Knight takes
bishop and now pawn takes Knight so this
is just imaginary these pawns
essentially being doubled that will be
resolved this exchange right here cannot
be avoided so this pawn would is going
to serve a useful role in watching over
this a 5 square so forget about a knight
being planted to that a 5 point
additionally there's just gonna be the
opening up right as soon as you capture
like that now these rooks are gonna have
play along this C file or you know it's
gonna be most likely a purposeful thing
to do with the rooks planting to that C
file sounds C takes D and now Knight to
d2 so this is definitely a point in the
game where you do have to come up with
the plan and that's not always the
easiest thing to come up with in a chess
game it's once you're beyond the point
of just getting your pieces out this
this next phase of really coming up with
the middle game plan is something to
really focus on and white is moving
forward with trying to eliminate the one
black piece that is finding itself in
the whites on the white side of the
board this e4 Knight so challenging it
right away this right here it seems very
sensible because really what is the
future of this f3 Knight it can't make
use of this square there's no way to
really influence this pawns movement
there's no way to chase it away from
defense of e5 so the next best thing is
likely to being Knight - D - just to
challenge it that's a useful role for
this night
get rid of this efore night of blacks so
after 92 black is wanting to just secure
this square and white pushes forward now
with f3 taking over control of this
efore square after Knight takes Knight
that's essentially forced otherwise that
Knights gonna get trapped if it goes to
g5 it's clearly now running out of
squares after h4 so Knight takes Knight
Queen takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
takes and it may be let's say a bit
tempting to want to capture towards the
center and build you know a pawn center
like this but it's certainly not without
maybe allowing black to put pressure on
this pond because now there's you know
black has this this file was once opened
and now I guess you could consider it
half open since there's now a white pawn
on it and this may very well find itself
being the target of an attack with moves
like the rooks doubling on these two
squares and moves like Bishop a6 or
timely d5 moves you may even see d5
right away so just avoiding maybe any
potential liability for this white pawn
being on the C file we just have the
Bishop recapturing and now black moving
forward with d5 so this is a pretty good
pawn structure here on the black end
chasing this bishop away where does it
go d3 definitely the best place looking
to now get in this efore advance so in
the meantime what does black deal rook
on F to ca I'm not quite sure if there's
a big big difference between which rook
gets played to that C file sometimes I
really I really do like to a question
why that rook instead of the other one
I'm not quite sure if there is a big
difference between the two but in any
event the rook on F played to c8 and
this is the only open file and
oftentimes in a chess game when there is
only one open file what you will often
see is both rooks eventually being
captured and maybe even the Queen's and
in this game we actually have none of
that going on so this is a very very
interesting point in fact right now on
White's next move
well in this position if you'd like to
pause the video which rook do you think
would be playing to this C file in this
position or maybe better said what was
the move played at this point in the
game if you like to pause the video see
if you can figure it out
okay it's actually neither rook playing
to that c1 square but rather rook on a
to e1 so this seems like a little bit
crazy maybe because in the meantime
black can be doubling on the C file and
that's exactly what's going on
we have rook c7 but what is this rook on
a one doing it's supporting this advance
so white is seeing that black could make
these moves which kind of our position
the rooks on squares where they just
kind of I guess look pretty but then
what are they doing beyond that that
that's all they that's all they're doing
at this point because really there's no
entry points if you're going to in a
chess game occupy an open file that next
thing you should be looking to do is
position your rook on let's say white
second rank or get down to the back rank
but there are no successful entry points
all these squares right here are covered
just by the bishops alone and it's not
an inconvenience whatsoever for the
bishops to be positioned like this
they're serving a good role in
particular this bishop for the moment
right now watching over that efore
square and so with this advanced now
with this advanced by white to this
efore square it starts to become very
difficult for black to deal with an
eventual pressing forward of the E&F
pawns looking to eventually create
additional open files now here on the E
and F files while these two rooks right
here again are just they look good but
they're really not serving a good role
so after E for we have black doubling
and now II five there really is not
going to be a way to maintain this nice
position however you look at it so if
black didn't move forward with the
doubling on the C and instead captured
like this well this is no now we have
play along the F file now black is
having to contend with maybe
timely d5 capture on f6 Queen out here
etc bad things can really happen if
black captures first because you're
allowing two different pawns to
potentially be moving forward and that's
that's going to be even more difficult
to be defending against when you give
your opponent two possibilities for
particular pawn moves so we just have
the doubling on the C file and now e5
pressing forward kicking this night away
the best defensive square that f6 square
the knight has to go elsewhere and it
decides to go to e 8 and white is just
pressing forward again looking to get
this pawn to f5 and black puts a quick
halt to it with g6 but right now we have
a rook lift so not getting this move in
just yet maybe there was thoughts of
let's say g4 and f5 but this this rook
lift is certainly a very forceful one as
well looking to come over to that H file
or maybe even the G file and who knows
maybe getting that Queen to h6 and
looking for mate so black is feeling
compelled at this point to make some
lateral defense for their King and maybe
trying to shut down this diagonal for
the bishop with their next move this f5
and white will certainly do best to keep
the position open and capture the Sun
you really do want to just open this
file keep this diagonal open so
certainly capturing is the way to go at
this point so e takes F Knight takes and
now the opening up of more files and
diagonals essentially if you're going to
be the side that has the bishop paired
the exchanging of pawns is going to
allow for more diagonals to open up so
we now have this diagonal opening up for
the Queen and really this is the last
piece needed to get activated on the
white side so with with f5 if the pawn
takes we could just have actually the
the rook or Bishop capturing because of
the the pin going on on the e-file so
after f5 we have the knight now planting
to this efore square and finally this
bishop is somewhat showing itself in the
position since
it's indirectly watching over that efore
square so this is essentially an
intolerable piece we saw earlier the one
Black Knight white got rid of it by
playing Knight to d2 and now the other
one is planted there and it's quickly
removed Bishop takes pawn takes Bishop
and now F takes G six so at this point
right here and these are maybe some of
the reasons which have attributed to
this game being known as sucker tortes
immortal it's the depth of calculation
right here it's knowing essentially five
moves down from this position what
exactly to be doing and there are a
couple of I guess you'd say bombs that
are dropped on this position in a short
time from now so a very critical point
is this one right here a lot of
calculation was certainly needed at this
point so moving forward F takes G six
and we now have rook c2 so certainly
strong calculation was needed at this
point hitting both Queen and Bishop if
the Queen moves right now we're just
going to have this bishop it's it's dead
so we don't have that just yet instead
first G takes H with check and now King
in the corner so this is often the case
in a chess game the the King will just
avoid capturing that pond so as to
shelter it a bit more kind of using this
white pawn as a defense for the black
side just kind of hiding behind it
otherwise we'd have rook h3 check that
sort of stuff going on so King goes to
the corner and now not a reaction just
yet to the rook threat on the Queen so
instead d5 and now we have a discovered
check on the King and black shuts down
that diagonal with E 5 and now here's
the very very interesting brilliant move
coming up if you'd like to pause the
video see if you can find White's next
move
okay the move is Queen to b4 the first
of I'd say a couple spectacular moves in
this position offering the Queen in
exchange for essentially the black King
because if Queen takes Queen at this
we're gonna have a mate in seven now
this this was not played but this is
just covering what would that mate in
seven look like well it's going to start
off with this Bishop finally coming to
life Bishop takes e5 with check King
takes pawn is the only move rook h3 if
the King plays here it's just going to
be a mate right away so the best
resistance I guess is seen with King to
g5 or King to g6 excuse me rook f6 and
if the King plays here we would have
check check and wherever the King goes
the bishop is going to give check and
then well actually if it goes here to be
mate and in the other direction we would
have first check and then mate one other
variation would be after this check
comes into play rook to f6 if King to g7
we would have rook check if the King
plays here it's just a quick mate and if
the King goes to the light square we
give check King here is forced check and
then finally mate so however you slice
it it's going to turn out to be mate if
the White Queen is captured in this
position right here so instead we have
rook to c5 and now white following up
with another one a really really
spectacular shot rook to f8 diverting
the Queen away from the defense of this
pun and if we have Queen takes rook here
now we have Bishop takes pawn King takes
Queen takes etc this is going to lead to
a quick mate if King here we could just
have Queen g6 and then mate next move or
if the King goes here we're just going
to have Mei coming up very quickly this
is I guess one way to go ahead and
finish off the game in fact there's like
four different mates from this position
pick your favorite one so that was not
the variation that was played after rook
landed a check on f8 we just have King
takes pawn and now the Queen could take
on e4 with check King g7 and the game
finishes up very nicely however there
was a quicker way to go ahead and win
we'll show that but we did have in the
actual game Bishop takes pawn King takes
rook Bishop to g7 trying to chase away
the King away from or chase away the
King from defense of the Queen
if King takes we're just going to be
grabbing that Queen and if Queen takes
bishop we would have a really nice mate
on that eh square but how this game
finished out Bishop to g7 King g8 Queen
takes Queen and black ended up resigning
so one other variation would have been
after King to g7 this rook check if
there if the King doesn't take the rook
it's going to be Queen to g6 and that's
mate right away so King takes rook it's
essentially just these two pieces alone
that could really kill black we could
have Queen check if the King goes to
either of these squares we'd have rook
going to let's say that f3 or h3 square
so we'd have something like this going
on which is going to be leading to mate
but as it was in this game after Bishop
takes King there
Bishop g7 King g8 Queen takes Queen
black ends up resigning so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye